[Music]
and we know from revelation chapter 12
verse 17 that the dragon who is the
devil makes war with this remnant
how does the dragon make war with god's
people is it a physical war
it is not a physical war the war in
heaven which the devil originated was
not necessarily a physical war
it is a war of the mind
the devil attacked this
god says thus said the lord
that here we receive it we reject we
don't accept it in the fist or the knee
or the toes we accept it in the mind so
the war is on the mind
through error and the weapon is error it
was error in heaven deception it was
error in eden when he fell and adam felt
consciously it was it has been errored
down through the ages the devil has
realized violence does not work when he
tried to persecute the church in a few
centuries after christ died the saying
arose the saying was the blood of the
martyrs is the seed of the church the
more he persecuted the church the church
grew what did he do he decided to drop
that that that approach not entirely but
generally and he chose deception
amalgamation now he mingled truth and
error and it worked beautifully so
people are destroyed pleasantly they're
not destroyed violently but the
destruction is the same
because spiritual destruction is worse
than physical destruction the devil uses
error and he uses religious entities to
promote that error which makes it so
deadly because no one would expect an
error to come from a church but the
devil uses a religious entity to spread
his error and his two basic errors are
the dead are not really dead and
sunday's the sabbath
the two fundamental errors with which he
has deceived the whole world revelation
12 verse nine
and so he makes war through twisting
truth we need to understand that
twisting truth and he did not twist
every expression of truth he just needs
to twist a central element of truth
which is the law of god and in that law
the seventh itself
so allah will be passed we know the
sunday law making sunday the legal day
of worship that's coming there's no law
past saying you know don't bear false
witness there's no law that we'll say
legally and thou shalt not whatever no
the law will be classed
will be passed
and making sabbath observance illegal
and sunday observance but this happened
hundreds of years ago
all the way back to the council of
laodicea when sabbath keeping was
outlawed
but it will really be worldwide it will
have teeth to it there will be a death
penalty
and so the devil makes war by tampering
with truth by tampering with the word of
god that's why you and i need to know
the word of god
and god has guaranteed us if any man
will do his will he shall know the
doctrine john 7 17 a desire to follow
god is essential to understand what
god's word says so the devil's warfare
is
twisting the truth it is the most
effective method of corrupting god's
people twisting the truth
when he came to christ temptation number
one attempt number two jump off the
temple he said for it is written he
shall give his angels charge over thee
but he did not say to keep the in all
thy ways he did not say that but he so
he used the word cleverly not too clever
for christ because christ saw through
his rubbish and so the devil uses the
word he twisted slightly he doesn't tell
you don't go to church he tells you you
know observe this day and if you go on
the several day he tells you don't do
that don't do that he finds at least one
thing to twist you or to trust me
thereby winning his victory but if we
cling to thus set the lord the devil
cannot overcome us
if you read matthew 8 16 and when the
evil was come they brought unto him many
that were possessed with devils and he
cast out the spirits with his word as it
worked then it worked before it will
work now our defense is the word and the
devil's target is the word
so we must know the lord
amen amen and sanctify them through thy
truth by the word that's right
and we see from before that the defining
characteristics of the remnant of god's
last eight people are those that keep
the commandments of god have the
testimony of jesus christ we have the
faith of jesus and what the devil does
is he tries to strip us of that
characteristic which is why it's so
important for us to get to know god on
an intimate level
his word through his word
you